no no no no Wow hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome to slender
adrift now this is a throwback not that
this game is old but I haven't played a
slender game in years and just recently
I played SCP containment breach which
kind of got me thinking about the old
horror games and I saw that this game
was fairly recent and reminiscent of the
original forests in slender so I'm gonna
give it a go if I have a dive mouse here
I don't think I do
Oh collect all five pages so in the
advent of the original Slender games
this one looks a little janky oh my god
is that the original building I don't
know if they tried to emulate what oh my
god it's the original building but
updated in HD whoo and by HD I mean
heavily dict
because this place doesn't look good at
all leave me alone you know you figure I
learn that after all these years that
slender just wants to be left alone it
doesn't actually want to be messed with
so I'm gonna get a de LAN why is it
right there electricity running through
the floor here and also mr. right
[ __ ] what and why how what is that oh
oh I can hear him Stimpy stomping all
over the woods that's not good for me
what the [ __ ]
alrighty then let's try that again
so getting the pages is a bit of a goof
and I seem that seemed a lot worse than
it has been in the past is it still
gonna be randomly generated oh there it
is hello alright got one long and
slender doesn't come a [ __ ] we're
gonna be fine alright [ __ ] by [ __ ] why
[ __ ] boy boy boy boy hey Ziggy zaggy
Ziggy zaggy oi oi oi Italy I can't hear
a much he's that's just concerning Wow
am I gonna get away from that where's
that crazy I don't know where is where
is he okay all right weird that's a
different mechanic than it was before so
I got to keep my eyes on you
oh where am I there's another building
or is it the same building or is that a
wall
ah I'm mistaking a building for a wall
cuz I'm an idiot well let's keep
stepping across it I don't know where
the hell I am or be will I be lost and
am [ __ ] so yes I know exactly where I
am and B where are you where where I
don't see you which is good and also bad
what what am I stuck on something I'm
stuck in a wall again I'm dumb
because I don't know where I am except
in the zone of being rubbernecked ah
known in it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah Nick yeah I got try to find
something before we were where my up on
a path how did I get up on a path I
can't see dick I mean it wouldn't be
good to see dick in this woods either
but I mean I seem to be making a lot of
dick references I'm gonna go down here
we find something in the channel
god damn how am I gonna find out other
goddamn pages I can't see in front of my
goddamn face oh hello well the geometry
seems to be a little broken here I deem
to be dick maybe I just like can I jump
over the walls here freedom freedom [ __ ]
you man
ha ha I've beaten your sis oh [ __ ] well
shitty dicks I don't think I was
supposed to come here oh hey hey hey
hiiiiii o yah yah yah yah go [ __ ]
yourself
and go die oh god where am i my back at
the building that I was just at but oh
[ __ ] hang on hey hey hey you're really
aggressive today being the day that it's
been three years since the last time I
saw you how about you stop huh you're
good with that good meat soon hey just
where are you is this a tunnel what am I
looking at no it's just my class Lavery
right oh [ __ ] I thought I saw tentacles
right okay fine we're not fine
Josh I die what's AG line of trees the
prison of trees look I don't know where
any other page would be there's only
four other pages but I'm completely
freaking lost man again this map isn't
exactly that big so how could I do that
got to stumble across one eventually
where's the landmarks where's the giant
red dildo come on
he'll do or dil-don't Oh God oh hey I
found another one is he gonna get more
aggressive good he should hey a rock oh
man my ancestors you to ride these bad
boys around for miles
what's weird it's a blood on the rock
great no page on that rock great I see
him satellite Wow hey why why why where
he be in front of me Devine me where am
i it's goddamn truck
there's something on the truck ah [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I'm just
checking the truck man just checking the
truck checking the there's nothing on
the truck where are you well I don't
like that okay so I found a landmark but
what does that mean
where are you at
hey hey fight fight fight Hey stranger
danger stranger danger stranger danger
stranger danger
got that stop stop sup hey look it's
light here why is it light here I don't
know why it's late here turn up another
page where did these goddamn light come
from straw bet
what are you dare when you flip dick and
dare don't you dare don't you dare on me
whoa I'm gonna get you okay no no no no
that was too close you get stuck on that
lamppost hey this is a big tree there's
something on this tree and now oh
there's a page okay I got three of five
you [ __ ]
hey yeah he's getting real spooky now
the spook levels have been cranked up to
hey stop it stop at stop gift shops to
upstair store app ah so these are the
walls but it was yeah four or five I
just need one more there's got to be
something on how to the truck [ __ ]
another thing rock this rock it's big
ass rock hey hey hey I'm almost done
with it I never beat the first game so
you're really cool yet maybe if that's
one don't do it don't [ __ ] die there
nothing on the rock they got nothing on
[ __ ] [ __ ]
we're a pipe hey hey hey where are you
where are you I judge no idea where you
are
where are you Grisi well looks like
there is okay alright then
that is [ __ ] impossible cuz you have
no I [ __ ] no no no no oh man I got
trapped in a goddamn hole ah [ __ ] hello
ah whoa whoa found a weird one in the
middle of nowhere if we can find that
truck I think that'll be the last one
okay
Oh what the [ __ ] is this hello hi do you
have a page you have AIDS
you're weird tunnel bastard where are
you there you are
okay so there's got to be the truck has
got to be somewhere oh here it is
please please come on your [ __ ]
where could it be it's got to be on one
of these things right right four of five
again I found like four other landmarks
but no pages on him unless I was just an
idiot and didn't see it okay I don't
know I can't find the last page I was
wandering there for about twenty minutes
straight I saw every landmark I
triple-checked everything
I don't know I don't know where the [ __ ]
that last page was so I'm gonna leave it
at that it's really interesting to be
back in slender and I know in the
original Slender I actually never beat
that game either but you know it's just
kind of nice to revisit the old
creepypastas and the old horror games
I'm kind of being true to my own 2013
self so thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to see this game
for yourself uh put a link in the
description below and maybe you can find
that last elusive page so thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]